[Musica]
tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di un posto
dove sentirci al sicuro un posto che ci
trasmetta un senso di protezione di
tranquillità di sicurezza quel posto noi
lo chiamiamo casa e riveste un ruolo
importantissimo per tutti noi
e quel luogo dove ogni sera vogliamo
tornare dopo una giornata di lavoro di
scuola o di impegni frenetici per
lasciarci alle spalle chiudendo quella
porta vogliamo chiudere di torino in
tutti i problemi li in quel luogo ci
vogliamo sentire al riparo e al sicuro
seguitemi per un attimo in questo
piccolo esperimento in sala tutti noi
chiudiamo gli occhi tutti quegli occhi
chiusi
iniziate immaginare di essere a casa
vostra
sono le nove di sera siete tranquilli se
te magari seduti a tavola con i vostri
familiari con i vostri cari estate
cenando oppure siete sul divano state
guardano la tv mi state rilassando e poi
sentite questo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ora
[Musica]
[Applauso]
era il 6 maggio del 1976 quando una
scossa di terremoto di 6.5 di magnitudo
colpì il friuli per puro caso
erano le nove di sera i due registratori
rimasero accesi e registrarono l'audio
che abbiamo appena sentito una scossa
devastante tanto da essere ricordata poi
in seguito come una delle più tremende
che colpì l'italia e da meritarsi un
appellativo
forse qualcuno di voi in sala se lo
ricorderà ora già sentito bene definita
lor colato lor colata è un termine
dispregiativo dialettale che sta a
indicare quell'essere a cui rimandiamo
le cause di quel terremoto lorca fu una
scossa eccezionale fu sentita dal centro
e nord italia da torino a roma ma anche
al di fuori dei nostri confini italiani
in parte della germania in francia in
ungheria e slovacchia portò devastazione
in 120 comuni non solo del fiuli venezia
giulia del veto ma anche dell'austria
della slovenia della croazia un comune
probabilmente in particolare fu colpito
a quello di gemona dove un mio collega
del centro comune di ricerca ha scattato
questa foto lui immediatamente dopo
quell'evento parti con la colonna dei
vigili del fuoco del centro che allora
si chiamava iurato per prestare soccorso
alle popolazioni colpite
sì perché a quel tempo non esisteva la
protezione civile non esistevano nemmeno
delle normative vera e propria
innovative per costruire una zona
sismica più di 40 anni sono passati e
tanta ricerca è stata fatta tanto
impegno a livello mondiale a livello
europeo per rendere i nostri edifici più
sicuri
questo grazie anche all'impegno profuso
dal centro comune di ricerca dove io
lavoro io ei miei colleghi lavoriamo in
un laboratorio per la valutazione
strutturale che noi più farmi larmente
chiamiamo elsa dove testiamo edifici a
scala reale alti fino a quattro piani
elsa è un laboratorio unico in europa è
il più grande del suo genere e lì io ai
miei colleghi abbiamo una missione
rendere più sicuri i nostri vostri
edifici e come lo facciamo lo facciamo
testando infrastrutture ponti strutture
prefabbricate o struttura in cemento in
calcestruzzo armato come quella che
potete vedere in questo video qui
scusatemi qui in questo video
abbiamo testato un edificio in cemento
armato e abbiamo applicato a questo
edificio di quattro piani delle azioni
le stesse azioni che si possono
sviluppare durante un sisma non sisma
anche di notevole entità per andare a
valutare come questo edificio potesse
comportarsi o le tecniche i materiali le
tecnologie che abbiamo applicato
potessero migliorare le sue prestazioni
abbiamo ottenuto molti risultati grazie
a questi test e non ci siamo focalizzati
solamente sugli edifici nuovi perché
dovete capire che le aree con più alto
rischio sismico sono anche quelle
caratterizzate da un patrimonio
immobiliare che si è costruito negli
anni quindi con tecniche con materiali
diversi e quindi noi abbiamo valutato
diversi materiali diverse tecnologie per
poter migliorare il suo comportamento il
loro comportamento ad esempio di
strutture in muratura
tutto questo lavoro che abbiamo svolto
noi in collaborazione con altri centri
di ricerca in giro per l'europa con
altra università ha permesso di
costituire uno strumento utilissimo
delle linee guida degli standard che ci
hanno permesso di costruire edifici più
sicuri
questi standard sono noti con il nome di
euro codici e ci permettono di
progettare realizzare e costruire
all'interno
non europea degli edifici sicuri hanno
un carattere innovativo tanto da essere
prese in considerazione anche al di
fuori dell'unione da stati che le stanno
valutando gli stanno applicando li
stanno utilizzando perché ritengono uno
strumento indispensabile una parte degli
eurocodici si dedica re costruzione in
zona sismica e fondamentalmente lì noi
ci poniamo tre obiettivi il primo il più
importante la salvaguardia della vita
umana
il secondo è quello di limitare i danni
causati da un terremoto ed infine il
terzo che si riferisce a delle
infrastrutture delle strutture
cosiddette critiche come gli ospedali
gli edifici la protezione civile che
devono rimanere operative anche dopo un
sisma eccezionale come vi dicevo tanti
risultati sono stati ottenuti però
ancora i terremoti ci colpiscono e
ancora portano devastazione
era il 2009 quando un sisma colpi la
l'aquila e causò più di 300 morti e poi
di nuovo nel 2016
un'altra sisma colpi una regione tra
l'aquila l'abruzzo e le marche
lì devastò decine di comuni e sotto le
macerie delle proprie case perso la vita
quasi 300 persone
avrete capito bene che c'è una chiave in
tutta questa narrazione degli elementi
importanti che sono gli edifici
ma vi siete mai chiesti che impatto
hanno gli edifici sulla nostra vita o
anche più semplicemente quanto tempo
trascorriamo all'interno dei nostri
edifici 15 16 ore
no in realtà ne trascorriamo molto di
più noi trascorriamo circa il 90 per
cento della nostra vita dentro un
edificio dalle 21 alle 22 ore tra a casa
ufficio scuola cinema supermercati
se poi pensiamo all'impatto che gli
edifici hanno sull'ambiente che ci
circonda non pensiamo semplicemente che
ogni anno viene prodotta una tonnellata
di calcestruzzo per essere umano per
costruire le nostre case le nostre
scuole e quindi abbiamo iniziato a
pensare a come rendere più sostenibili i
nostri edifici anche da un punto di
vista energetico delle proprie
performance energetica degli edifici
perché dovete ricordarvi che il 40 per
cento di tutta l'energia che è consumata
in europa è consumata dagli edifici e il
20 per cento di questa energia
letteramente fluisce fuori dai nostri
muri delle nostre finestre e allora
abbiamo investito tempo e denaro ricerca
per poter migliorare le performance
energetiche ai nuovi materiali nuovi
isolamenti per rendere la precedente
energetico di note edifici migliore
attraverso pannelli solari
abbiamo iniziato ad appoggiare personali
sopra tutti i tetti delle nostre città e
se non mi credete pensate siamo riusciti
anche a ad appoggiarli sopra i tetti
della città del vaticano
e tutto questo va benissimo
tutta questa attenzione che abbiamo
apposto su questi concetti di
sostenibilità di performance energetiche
sono ottimi ma noi poniamo la stessa
attenzione quando andiamo a considerare
la sicurezza quando stiamo comprando una
nuova casa poniamo la stessa attenzione
alla sicurezza dentro questa casa o alle
case che viviamo tutt'oggi oppure ci
limitiamo a proteggersi da possibili
intrusioni completamente dimenticandoci
i rischi che ci pone la natura che ci
circonda
l'impatto che questa può avere sui
nostri edifici e bene
noi dobbiamo porre attenzione su questi
su questi temi sono temi fondamentali
perché dobbiamo fermarci e ricordarci
che questi sono temi importanti perché
poi a un certo punto le notizie dei
luoghi di devastazione iniziano svanire
in media passano ad altri argomenti
le immagini dei luoghi di devastazione
diventano qualcosa di lontano un tragico
ricordo qualcosa che accaduto a qualcun
altro
persino le persone vanno oltre alla
perdita di vite umane che ci sono state
in quegli eventi
noi pensiamo che sia qualcosa che possa
succedere a qualcun altro ma non possa
succedere a noi ma così non è e quindi
non dobbiamo dimenticare dobbiamo
fermarci a riflettere su come poter fare
per ridurre per evitare nuove
devastazioni come quelle che abbiamo
visto e mi raccomando non basta che
soltanto uno di noi
poi un attenzione a questi temi perché
se vogliamo avere una comunità che sia
residente ossia che sia in grado di
rimettersi in piedi dopo uno choc
tremendo come quello di un terremoto non
basta uno di noi che pone attenzione c'è
bisogno di tutti noi di tutti i
cittadini
dobbiamo andare oltre quei confini
mentali che ci fanno pensare che le cose
le tragedie possono succedere agli altri
o che ci fanno pensare solamente alla
relazione tra nostre case e l'ambiente
che ci circonda come qualcosa di
unidirezionale perché in realtà non
dobbiamo pensare solamente all'impatto
che i nostri uffici hanno sulla natura
ma anche a quello che la natura pone
come rischio sulle sui nostri edifici
sulle persone che ci vivono al loro
interno e dobbiamo agire dobbiamo agire
per ridurre quei rischi la tecnologia
per farlo c'è e dobbiamo agire ora
perché se no continueremo ad investire
milioni e milioni di euro per appoggiare
dei pannelli fotovoltaici su dei
castelli
carta grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]